[Music]
fuck Lucas stop psycho
max you'll impeach with Intex
super-strength
he's the world's strongest coolest
secret agent act stop sign go ready
combat diver suit full underwater
breathing activate going turbo cyclos
getting away hydrogen ready yeah
convert to off-road in like 16 hydrogen
Vic combat diver and psycho figure t so
separate color changes one more from the
acclaimed director of the 2009 horror
remake sorority row comes a film based
off of Mattel's line of action figures a
young teenage boy max McGrath moves to a
small town with his mom after losing his
father and discovers that he has strange
powers some form of energy is seeping
out of his fingers he can control
electronic devices and he may just have
a robotic friend following him
everywhere who lost his memory so I went
and saw this film today because there
were no press screenings and there were
no late-night Thursday showings like I
usually go to if there are no press
screenings and I was completely alone in
this theater that sometimes happens to
me in the middle of the night but not at
4:30 p.m. that's not good now let me get
this right out of the gate I never
played with any of these toys growing up
I didn't see any of the trailers for
this movie I never watched either of the
animated TV shows I don't give a shit
about max steel so I went to this movie
with a completely open mind and I gotta
say I was blown away there is so much
shit I want to talk about so look I have
to do something I don't usually do this
with new releases but it has to be done
this film
I can't review without spoiling I can't
I have to I will not feel complete
within myself unless I talk about this
film in depth so I apologize if any of
you are deeply invested in the release
of max steel I'm sorry this review is
going to contain spoilers I don't even
know where to start so let's just start
with the acting it's bad all around
everyone's bad maria bello is fine she's
probably the one saving grace in this
entire film she's okay the lead actor in
this film is unforgivably bland there
isn't a thing about him that's
charismatic there's no energy that seems
to be seeping from him I can't really
blame all this on him though because
this film is shot and edited together so
poorly that the entire production feels
almost as if it was just a rights
retaining movie do you know what I mean
a movie that was made by a studio
because they're fearing they're going to
lose rights to a property that they
maybe want to do something with one day
so they better make a movie real quick
otherwise somebody else is going to buy
up these rights that's what this movie
feels like very early on you notice that
the editing in this film is going to be
very awkward with a very strange dinner
scene where andy garcia maria bello and
this kid they're all having dinner
together and it's intercut with these
SWAT guys or some force of some kind
that are breaking into this facility and
it's like action suspense action oh it's
back to some dinner jokes action
suspense action back to dinner jokes
it's horrible it's almost as if they
were trying to time it to be funny in
some way you know how sometimes in a
movie or you have a really fast-paced
scene and then you cut back really quick
to somebody who's doing something more
mundane the score drains out and it's
supposed to make you laugh it seems like
they were going for that and it just
felt completely flat the editing in this
entire film feels that way it doesn't
seem to understand what type of movie it
is is it a comedy is it a romance is it
a superhero movie what is this movie
[Music]
why don't you guys try to guess how the
romance is started in this film between
the young boy and the young girl just
guess yeah they run into each other how
many times in movies does a couple just
round a corner run into each other go my
god
oh I'm sorry Reza you're sexy and then
this girl spends the rest of the film
stalking this guy this is one of the
worst written female characters of the
entire year she has no purpose in this
film other than to for some reason
continuously follow this boy everywhere
he goes despite the fact that because of
his weird bodily reactions he's having
to these strange things that are
happening to him he keeps ditching her
and he keeps blowing her off because he
doesn't want to freak her out
when electric energy starts coming out
of him and she continuously follows him
and tries to pick him up and always
looks for ways to get with this boy and
I'm like how desperate is this girl
she's very pretty
she seems smart does she not have
anything better to do than to follow the
new kid who keeps ditching her at every
turn it's such a terrible character and
for whatever reason throughout this
movie every time this kid goes into his
room a kung-fu movie is playing in the
background
it's like indefinitely he has a marathon
of kung-fu movies that are always
playing on his TV and I'm not talking
about like he comes in his room and then
turns on the TV and that's just on every
time this character is seen walking into
his room there is already a television
on with a kung fu movie
[Music]
Biocon let me give you a hand
I can explain how bad this movie is by
just talking about one scene I'm gonna
try to do it without laughing my ass off
this kid after he has all this weird
stuff happened to him and stuff is
coming out of his fingers and he's
controlling electronic devices he goes
into his room fires up Google and types
in my fingers emit liquid energy search
when this dumb ass that we're supposed
to care about of course can't find
anything he then types in what am I on
Google there's also a ton of logical
flaws like they live right by this
gigantic power Factory and when they go
outside they can see like every star in
the solar system and then like halfway
through this movie a flying robot named
steel shows up and starts talking to max
about everything apparently he has a
weird past but the robot can't remember
the past he's lost his memory of course
because of the robot could just tell max
what he needed to know the movie would
be over but for whatever reason they of
course make the robot lose his memory
the screenplay is so lazy that when the
robot tells max he can explain anything
he wants to know max is like okay what's
with all this liquid energy stuff and
the robot goes pass now this could
potentially be funny if the dialogue had
any bite to it but it doesn't of course
what was I expecting this movies based
off a fucking action figure and how was
this kid not like freaking the hell out
weird shit is coming out of his fingers
he can control electronic devices he's
blacking out in the middle of the woods
waking up with rashes and his clothes
are burnt and now a sarcastic robot is
following him everywhere and he's just
like yeah man my life really sucks Oh No
the girl I like I can't really be with
her cuz weird shits coming out of my
hands damn
the adventure continues as Max and his
trusty canine assault dog hot on cycles
trey is he close wreck so like randomly
just like out of nowhere this kid
realizes he's suddenly super strong and
he can sort of will a suit into
existence he just like gets really
excited all of a sudden and becomes
Starkid that movie from 1997 and of
course Andy Garcia shows up in a few
scenes every once in a while just to
make sure that his paycheck clears now
the second Andy Garcia walked on frame
in the beginning of this movie and was
just like a nice friendly guy who showed
up for a nice dinner I was like yeah
he's the main villain there's no way an
actor of that caliber signed on to this
movie unless he's the villain and of
course he is it's so predictable and
it's the most obvious stunt double
whenever he's fighting max at the end in
the suit it looks like one of the bad
Power Rangers episodes I mean this kid
discovers that he has these abilities he
realizes he can go super fast you can go
like from from here they're in a split
second later in the movie there's a big
tornado following this kid and for
whatever reason he chooses not to use
his super speed at this point that might
be the best time actually to use super
speed when there is like an f5 tornado
directly behind you with a giant fucking
creature in it also the main character
is a complete idiot there's a scene
where his mom's in jeopardy and he calls
somebody he's like hey I need your help
I don't know where mom is is she okay
and he's like oh yeah there's only one
place she could possibly be go to that
place and the guy on the phone is like
no listen very carefully this is very
essential
hang up driver you're seriously about to
hang up when the guy who tells you where
your mom might be when she's in jeopardy
says listen very carefully this is
essential how am I supposed to like this
guy how am I supposed to give a shit
about him he's also a complete coward
now look sometimes in movies it's about
a hero blossoming into a hero it's about
maybe he starts out small like Peter
Parker and eventually becomes spider-man
towards the end of the movie there's
like a team of SWAT guys that show up
and are like protect the boy and start
shooting at the bad guy who was trying
to kill max max then goes in a corner
and hides letting the main villain kill
the entire team
I mean like brutally murder them they're
dead and he's just over in the corner
like I can't do this how am I supposed
to give a shit about this guy this is
the very end of the movie and he finally
at some point decides they I have an
idea
he decides to let Andy Garcia just suck
all of the energy out of him until he
fucking explodes which is like the
biggest cliche whenever there's a
power-hungry baddie well you should just
give him all the power he wants because
he's gonna blow up
[Music]
and of course at the end there's like a
big revealing flashback that lets us
know everything the robot suddenly has
his memory max has his memory they all
get their memories back and it's just a
bunch of techno babble that really
doesn't mean anything and it's supposed
to make us feel like we're listening to
scientists talk I hate this movie
max steel of course gets an F don't
worry about seeing this one I feel bad
for you if you are a fan of the show or
the toys I guess but once again we have
yet another film based off of a toy line
that's awful
max activates Rex's leapin action and
since cycles of the edge reality bites
guys thank you so much as always for
watching you the best and if you liked
this you click right here and get stuck
man eyes
you
[Music]